all right Sam I want to play a game I
want to start this with a game where I'm
going to read you the and you don't know
this by the way you didn't know I was
going to do this we have the I'm going
to read you the most trafficed websites
in the United States and it's a simple
test you're a business guy you study the
business world I want you to tell me do
you know who's the owner or CEO of these
businesses okay all right I like this
game number one google.com Sergey and
Larry pagee Sergey something and Larry
pagee correct uh next one YouTube um
Chad h and y and Jared and one other guy
Steve Chen exactly correct um Reddit
Huffman and Ohanian correct uh Amazon
Bezos okay number five now we're getting
we're getting to the good stuff okay so
first this is I think you'll get this
one easy Facebook Zuckerberg okay number
six PornHub uh Bastion something a
German guy incorrect sir
[Music]
so this is the number sixth most
trafficked website in the United States
three billion visits um in in like in a
month is it called mindgeek or Mind
Freak or something mindgeek is a name of
a company that owned it um however the
founding story is pretty crazy and I
don't know if you're a Sci-Fi guy or a
fantasy guy but in in many fantasy book
series there's this Con there's like
this this concept like in The Lord of
the Rings there's the ring or um in uh
Harry Potter there's the Elder Wand and
it's an idea that there's so there's
these assets that are so powerful that
people want to own it but whenever you
own it your ownership's going to be very
short-lived uh it's almost like the the
the item is too powerful it sort of
corrupts you and uh puts a Target on
your back and other people start coming
for you it's a real sticky situation one
might
say this is like it's Game of Thrones
right everybody wants to sit on the iron
throne but when you're on the Iron
Throne you're not going to last very
long and so this is a Game of Thrones
style story for Tech that I went down a
rabbit hole I want to share with you
because I didn't know this story so let
me tell you let me tell you how it went
down okay so we rewind the clock we go
back to 2005 up until then you know
Internet's been out for rough been been
semi- mainstream for 10 years and of
course porn was popular right away but
the way that all porn sites worked was
it was like Yahoo it was a directory of
links so you would go to um whatever I
don't know Juggworld decom and it would
just it would just show you a hundred
links to places where you could go watch
videos not the videos but to the other
websites links to other websites or
links to other photos mostly photos at
the time it wasn't even that much video
so 2005 a big milestone happens which is
that YouTube launches and YouTube
launches with a pretty simple
proposition which is we'll make it
really easy to host a video online you
don't have to host it on your own
servers we'll host it on our servers and
then also instead of just sending
somebody that file you send them a just
a link and they can watch it here and
we'll just have all the videos here in
one place which was mindblowing sounds
so obvious now but at the time was
different and if you haven't read it go
read the Sequoia memo of his investment
uh roll off about this investment in
YouTube if you want to see how like
uncertain and how like small and
non-obvious this was at the beginning so
YouTube launches it starts to get
popular now there's copycats that come
out in the porn version of this red tube
right just off of YouTube red tube um
You Porn whatever a bunch bunch of these
come out and they're all flooded with
pirated content so they're just like
kind of like lime wire back in the day
they just take you know stuff that
you're supposed to pay for and they
would just upload it for free on here
and they would have you know banner ads
to make money and even though these were
um kind of sketchy websites they were
10x better in every way so it was more
private right you didn't have to go
anywhere you could just have it in your
bedroom um it was instantaneous right
the the distance between the craving the
Fulfillment of the craving were were you
know one click away there was infinite
variety so you didn't have to pick and
choose you could just keep going till
you find what you like there's infinite
niches and so people discovered that
people were into all kinds of weird
stuff because now there was a longtail
of content and it was free whereas most
point at the time was pain uh because at
the time there was somebody who was
called the King of Porn he the guy who
was sitting on the G on the Iron Throne
at the time and this was the CEO of
Vivid Entertainment what is and what was
Vivid Entertainment they're like a
Hollywood studio they're making like you
know porn or normal movies no they're
making porn but they're making it like
in the Hollywood way where there's like
an actress and there's a set and there's
cameraman there's like and people buy
DVDs yeah buy buy the DVD and so vivid
at the time was the king this guy was
known as the King of Porn he was written
up at all these articles in fact the
year that he was written up all these
articles is the same year these new
disruptive websites came out and revenue
starts to fall and it falls 50% and it
falls 80% it just basically goes down
the drain how big was it uh it was doing
tens of millions in Revenue um but there
were many studios like this so they were
they were the biggest one but there was
like you know just like in Hollywood
there's many studios all right so I
don't know if you remember Google uh
Google bought YouTube because YouTube
was getting a had a huge lawsuit from
Viacom these are like parallel stories
YouTube was also flooded with pirated
content because of that they were
getting sued like crazy and because they
were worried that they would go out of
business they sold to Google for like a
billion a half dollars at the same time
Vivid copies that Playbook they look at
what viacom's doing to YouTube they
start suing the crap out of all the the
website and so the first owner of the
throne Vivid goes down then the second
owner of the throne which was these like
red tube and whatever they they start
getting hammered as well because they're
getting sued all right so who's the
third one to pick up the the the Baton
and where does PornHub come into this
okay so so at the time there's three
college students in Canada and they
realized that this is a u that like
there's a lot of traffic uh to these
websites they meet of out of all things
at a competitive foosball tournament and
the guy who's the best fball player AKA
Chief nerd uh right like sir dork um he
happens to be the best programmer of the
bunch and he creates a live streaming
video website to stream their foosball
competitions and there's not much of an
audience for the Foosball competitions
but he realizes as he's building all
this video tech he's like hey I think we
could do the same thing for porn was the
intention porn or was the intention
something else and porn users used it
used it most so these guys made the link
site so that site I talked about jug
world that's their site but they made
like a hundred of these um they made
like a 100 directory sites just links to
other websites then they see the YouTube
thing and they pick up this guy Matt I
think his name Matthew keer or something
keer is the guy who built a video
streaming site he's the best programmer
so he's like I think I can can make a
YouTube for for this stuff and we can
instead of having these directories
where we send the traffic away we could
just keep the traffic and uh at the time
they had already kind of like you know
started to discover things they're like
oh people like you know people like this
people like this they were just creating
other directories and eventually they
looked at Vivid who was the king at the
time and they were like we should make
our own Vivid and so in the same office
they created PornHub the website that
was going to host all this stuff and
they created a company called BRZ
which is a oh yeah producer of content
so they created a Content producer and
they created the platform the network
making their own shows exactly or like
you know um FTX had the you know sister
company that and by the way nobody knew
these companies were linked so everybody
thought these were two uh not only
unlined companies they thought they were
enemies because at the time all of the
studios were hated the platforms that
were giving away the content for free
people didn't know that one of the
biggest Studios be you know was actually
the owner of one of the biggest websites
at the time and so in the same way that
there was FTX and Alam living in the
same house you know kind of sharing
funds brazers and PornHub were doing the
same thing people just didn't know in
fact the guy came out and was like
quoted uh he was like that would be that
would make no sense why would we do that
that would be 100% against our core
interest as brazers to do that we hate
the platforms and meanwhile he was also
the owner so these guys start this thing
and it takes off like a rocket they
they're like dude we have no idea what
we fell into we were sleeping in the
office we worked every single day every
every weekend we couldn't hire enough
this was now like 2007 or eight I think
so they weren't the first mover but they
were they ended up becoming the biggest
mover and here's why so they basically
scaled this thing better than anyone
else could and one of the keys was they
had brazers they had their own content
that was not uh not pirated or like it
was pirated but they owned it so they
didn't care that they could use on the
network so even when other stuff got
taken down they still had more content
than other people all right everyone a
quick break to tell you about HubSpot
and this one is really easy for me to
talk about because I'm going to show you
a real life example so I've got this
company called Hampton join hampton.com
it's a community for Founders doing
between 2 million all the way up to like
$250 million a year in revenue and one
of the ways that we've grown is we've
created these cool surveys and so we
have a lot of Founders who have high net
worths and we'll ask them all types of
questions that people typically are
embarrassed to ask but provide a lot of
value so things like how much the
founders pay themselves each month how
much money they're spending each month
what their payroll looks like if they're
optimistic about the next year and their
business all these questions that people
are afraid to ask but well we ask them
anyway and they tell us in this
Anonymous survey and so what we do is we
created a landing page using hubspot's
landing page tool and it basically has a
landing page that says here's all the
questions we asked give us your email if
you want to access it and then I shared
this page on Twitter and we were able to
get thousands of people who gave us
their email and told us they want this
survey and I could see did they come
from social media I can see did they
come from Twitter from LinkedIn
basically everywhere else that they
could possibly come from I'm able to
track all of that and then I'm able to
see over the next handful of weeks how
many of those people actually signed up
and became a member of Hampton in other
words I can see how much revenue came
from this survey how much revenue came
from each traffic Source things like
that but the best part is I can see how
much revenue came from it but a lot of
times it takes a ton of work to make
that happen HubSpot made that super
super easy if you're interested in doing
this you can check it out hubspot.com
the Link's in the description and I'll
also put the link to the survey that I
did so you can actually see the landing
page and how it worked and everything
like that I'm just going to do that call
to action
then and it's free check it out in thep
description all right now back to MFM
and so they scaled up they they go from
basically like just three friends to
like 80 people 150 people 250 people and
they're hiring friends and family and
they're like dude they're like where do
we we have an office they're like no no
no just they started buying houses next
to each other just created a
neighborhood and they're all just
working out of that like that one area
bootstrapped bootstrapped no no
investors no nothing so just growing
because Word of Mouth traffic and
obviously people love what their their
product and they're just coming back
over and over again again and the key is
that this guy keer was an SEO Savant he
came out later and he goes we were the
number one rank for porn and sex on
Google he's like do you know how hard
how competitive that is he's like I he's
like that's what I did I pulled that off
I became the number one search that's
how we defeated all of the other things
and then we had content that wasn't
getting taken down so they grow it to
250 they make one of the guys Brothers
the CEO they're like you're the CEO you
have some business experience you do
this so that guy starts doing a rollup
like a private Equity rollup so he
starts buying up all the other ones who
are afraid of getting sued and so he's
buying them up for cheap and he's just
consolidating power um and just creating
one big Mega Behemoth because then he
could fight whoever was going to sue
them because now they owned all the
traffic so they had something you know
they had something to to um to fight
with and so he starts building this
thing up and by the way there's this
whole like industry is so funny because
you think of it as a sketchy thing but
like one of the sites for example that
they bought it was called homegrown it
was started as a a VHS tape Exchange for
like swinger couples right like the most
like Fringe Of The Fringe thing but this
kid who's a Stanford NBA student buys it
his mom helps him raise the money and
they do a they do like a leverage buyout
of this thing like it was actually kind
of sophisticated under the hood even
though on the surface it looked like you
know these you know really sketchy gray
area things but it's like Stanford NBA
are buying this stuff so anyways fast
forward to 2009 they've scaled it to 250
employees they're making millions and
millions of dollars right they're making
more money than they ever knew what to
do with but they're getting par oid
because they know you're sitting on the
on the throne that people are going to
come for you and so uh they start seeing
some bad stuff right the government
seizes $9 million out of one of their
bank accounts just just takes it and
they're like [__] what do we do they
start trying to move money around they
hire security 247 they're followed by
you know black tinted SUVs the kezer guy
the SEO guy he just quits he's like I I
can't take this anymore it's too
stressful they're like dude you're
walking away from so much money he's
like I don't care I can't handle this so
they finally just decide look it's too
stressful we can't do this anymore
let's cash out now there's not a lot of
buyers for this thing right because
institutional investors can't really buy
this type of asset and now it's big how
big like was worth over100 million do so
they sell it to that guy you were
referring to this guy Fabian Tillman 100
so 140 million is what they sold it to
him for when what was what was his
background fabian's background was I
think he had also he was already um in
this space so what he did was this guy
was like a programming genius so at 17
he basically started he created a
website that was just for internet
traffic so it's like Alexa right like
internet traffic sites uh St statistics
sorry so he's just a nerd he loves the
internet so he creates a site that
tracks um successful internet uh
companies which which ones are growing
the fastest however you know how I
started this by reading you like what's
the sixth most popular website in in the
United States he sees that the most
popular websites are all porn websites
and so he's like huh what if I create
software for them so he goes to them
he's like what do you need and they're
like well you know one of the hard
things is we
uh we make money off of Affiliates but
our affiliate tracking sucks so he
builds an affiliate tracking tool that
becomes the number one most used uh
piece of code for affiliate tracking on
the internet and it's being used by
these porn websites and he builds that
company up he's super young he's like
you know 20 years old or something he
sells it he's super rich now he's got
hundreds of millions of dollars and so
he then goes and he buys PornHub for
$140 million and then he just like
grows it like crazy so he in I think in
I think in like three to six months he
doubled the profits of the business
because he's this guy's just a better
operator he knew how to monetize better
and he also knew how to like um to to
solve the problems around the content
licensing so he spends a million dollars
buying content licensing rights so that
they don't get uh sued anymore he
changes the name he launches like a PR
campaign around safe sex and he starts
like you know getting in with
politicians and all this stuff right and
he's doing he tries to to do other stuff
too he he buys celebs.com and tries to
create a TMZ he tries to create like a
bigger media Empire but nothing nothing
can keep up with the growth of the core
asset and so he's 30 you know he ends up
uh 32 years old this you know the
company has 500 employees and he's the
biggest porn Tycoon on the planet now
and this guy has sort of made it however
there is one problem and this problem is
that like I said this the great power
corrupts and people puts a Target on his
back people start coming after him and
he's hard to find too right if you would
look for photos of this guy Google like
you actually can't see that many
pictures of him right well he did a
couple interviews at Tech conferences
later when they started to try to like
Branch out similar to how only fans has
tried to Branch out and hire like
musicians be like hey show behind the
scenes cont content of your your music
process or whatever they're trying to
Branch out um he tried to do the same
kind of hard when your name is Pornhub
though well he created other websites
right so he created separate websites
altogether that he wanted to use the
same team and cash to to to start but
crazy stuff is happening right so like
he uh he's on one hand he's figuring out
how to monetize it way better and he's
like oh like and then by the way he's
hiring like data scientists and the data
scientists are like sir we found it the
best way to get a free user to pay for
content is a video that is 2 minutes and
59 seconds and that is the point where a
man is most committed and is willing
like you know to impulsively buy
something if we try to put a pay wall
before that or after that it's not going
to work 2 minutes and 59 seconds is what
we just found as the optimal time in
order to like increase revenue and they
do they increase Revenue a lot oh
there's one other thing I didn't mention
which is along the way people start to
get curious they're like okay he's
building this huge Empire he's rolling
up all these sites he's buying more and
more sites like how much cash does this
guy have how did he generate so much
cash and what later comes out is that he
got a $362 million loan from a unknown
secret investors and it turns out that
basically there was two guys who he went
to all the big Banks and the big Banks
were like look we can't do this we can't
lend the money so he goes to privates
and it turns out he raised from 125
secret lenders they their names have not
been revealed except for one group their
names have been revealed it was a bunch
of X I don't know if it was JP Morgan or
Morgan Stanley or whatever some some big
Bank two Bankers from there spun out
created their own like lending firm
specifically to lend just to this one
play they're like this is going to be so
lucrative that we have to just leave our
jobs quit our jobs raise money and just
lend it to this guy and they lended it
at a 20% interest rate and so even
though he was growing and making all
this money he had huge like monthly
commitments because he raises 360
million at 20% interest yeah so his his
his his debt payment or his interest
payment is 80 or $100 million a year 60
million a year exactly and and they're
and they're also under attack like the
CEO he owns a $16 million house it gets
burned down by arsonist and Bill Amman
comes into the Fright do you want to
know how Bill akman comes into this into
this story so in the Game of Thrones now
Bill aan comes in from Westeros and he's
like he's reading an article one day
this is the story I don't know how true
this is but the story is he's reading an
article in the New York Times and it's
about a girl a teenage girl who's sent
nude photos to her boyfriend the
boyfriend then leaked it onto one of
these websites and amman's like that's
so wrong and she couldn't get it taken
down and and she's felt so bullied and
whatever he's got daughters he's like
this is terrible and so he's like he's
and so you know how right now he's on a
crusade to take down Harvard take down
Business Insider he goes on a crusade to
take down pornhup and so he's he tries
to find him he's like dude this is like
some offshore Company by this German you
know single owner I can't pressure him
he's not a public stock I can't become
an activist what can I do he's like so
he thinks about it first he's stumped
then he's like wait a minute what if I
like you know when the US government
sanctions Russia he's like what if I
sanction pornhub by cutting off their
flow of money so he's like hey they need
payment processors and so what Bill
Amman does is he goes and he immediately
texts the CEO of visa and he sends him
the article he's like your company is
enabling this these guys are making
money off of this you better do
something uh about this and the CEO Visa
is like dude I don't want any trouble
from Bill Amman agrees that it's the
wrong you know it's wrong it's not a
huge portion of Visa's revenue and he
texts him back I'm on it like within
five minutes I'm on it one day later
Visa cuts off uh pornup so does
MasterCard so does you know so they they
lose their ability to actually process
payments until they later like you know
um had to change all their policies they
like now verify everybody with their
license and [__] like that in order to
Billman has this old tweet he goes if
you've been victimized by pornhub or any
of their Affiliates you may be eligible
for a large amount of compensation I
encourage you to email this person who
consules 70 plus victims who can help
you pursue your claim so he like puts
all his weight behind this thing this is
this is pre- Israel pre Harvard pre-
Business Insider yeah the PornHub is is
is who he's going after Hell hath no
fury like Bill akman scorned right like
yeah
he is he is he goes after you so the
crazy part is the story doesn't end
there so you I thought and you thought
that PornHub was owned by a company
called mindgeek and mindgeek is run by
this guy Fabian Tillman however a few
years ago uh or sorry three three or
four years into owning it he's grown the
company like crazy however he gets inou
trouble for tax uh tax fraud or tax like
evasion or something like that he and
he's in Germany I don't know all the
details around the tax thing but I know
that he gets a trouble on taxes he's
forced to sell in a fire sale he sells
it for $77 million oh wow so the value
has gone down somehow the sixth most
trafficed website in America sells for
$77
million that's how much morning Brew
sold for like come on dude this is this
is the only time where I'm allowed to go
on PornHub on my work computer so I can
look at their stats so according to
similar web PornHub gets two billion
visits a month average uh visit duration
10 minutes which is a lot and 10 pages
per visit so just get a ton of traffic
so it's just huge and by the way now let
me tell you so this is a two adventure
story aren't you curious what happened
to those original Founders who sold it
for the 140 million what are they doing
now I'm I'm curious about them and I'm
curious about who who bought PornHub to
for 77 million so which one do you want
do you want to know about the shadowy
businessman who bought it or do you want
to know about the original Founders
Choose Your Own Adventure let's I want
to go both but I want to go with the
original for for now so if you go look
at their LinkedIn now which I did what's
their name
so one guy's name I mean the so one is
Stefan Manos another one is usam YF and
then there's the guy keer um all of them
if you go to their linkedin's now there
is uh no mention of uh of any of this
they they're like yeah we it's all about
their philanthropy it's whatever but
here's the interesting thing so they guy
youf he sells and he's like okay I just
want to get away from all this that was
too stressful too sketchy it became way
bigger than we started started it like
we didn't intend to do that it just sort
of one thing led to another I need to
reset and in his reset year he's like
well what do I how do I invest all this
money I have and so he starts reading
and he reads 150 books about investing
and he comes away a Warren Buffett
disciple and he's like you know what I'm
gonna go into value investing and he
creates a a Burkshire haway for internet
companies called valf and valf is
basically like constellation software uh
they're just buying up profitable cash
flowing uh internet companies dude and
they're killing it they're killing
killing it they're now they're now it's
a billion dollar company now they have
over a hundred million in eida every
year uh just from they've acquired like
whatever 50 companies or so they have
like 500 million in revenues and then
they have like 20 to 30% net profit
margins and just listen to the guy so
they create this thing called the valf
group and they're like all right we're
going to uh you know first they start
buying up like other content websites
because that's what they know and then
they start studying constellation
software which is the same thing that
Andrew Wilkinson did and several many
other people have done because
constellation is like what are the ogs
of this and he's like huh I read the
stuff that Warren Buffett was doing on
the stock market but this private
private software companies is even
better he goes it's 10 times better
because there's only there's like 30,000
of these companies and there's no
competition to buy them what year what
year is this 2016 wow and so he um he
starts copying their playbook and he's
like look this Market is opaque it's
inefficient um I think you could deploy
a high rate of capital and get economics
similar to what you know the Mogul of
the previous times were so he's like
Murdoch you know he rolled up cable and
newspapers back in the 50s and 60s he's
like that's what I think I'm going to be
able to do with these you know
profitable software companies example of
their companies are nitar a cloud-based
car rental software company designed to
automate a bunch of the stuff or it's
like a construction software business
just like things that you don't even
know exist but like this one has been
around that's called Mal Mac practice
since 2004 it started in Lincoln
Nebraska it's created best-in-class
software for chiropractors exactly so
the first company they bought 2016 is
something that sells software to small
hotels then the next year they buy three
the next year they buy eight now they're
buying 20 to 25 a year and they're just
buying them that are like they're small
and the same thing that constellation
does so I think constellation bought
like thousands of companies during the
last few years I think the average siiz
constellation software business is $3
million in Revenue isn't it exactly
exactly and so uh I don't know if it's
revenue or EB but it's small they're not
like it's not huge PE deals it's the
same thing these guys are looking for
companies that are 5 to 10 million in
revenue and so they go uh and they
they're just studing constellation
they're like it's great basically you
buy them you need them to run on their
own individually so that it doesn't add
more bloat to headquarters and they're
just buying stuff all over Europe and
he's like uh he goes right now my
problem is I'm trying to decide between
a great opportunity and a good
opportunity which is just this guy's
great did he part and I think he
partnered with some of the other the
other Founders right it was two I think
two or three of them that know it was
two of them Yousef and the Manos one I
don't know what the keyzer guy does now
they don't even mention PornHub on so if
you go to Val soft.com or history like
that that word's not even mentioned
anywhere yeah there's parts of my
history I don't mention either right
like we all we get it um these guys are
planning to go IP which is pretty pretty
crazy so that's where these guys went
which is insane now what happened to the
site who bought it so the story that
came out was that the you know who's the
next person on the throne they said that
actually the employees bought it out for
77 million like the two Executives uh
bought it out but that didn't smell
quite right where do these ex where do
these employees get $77 million to buy
this right like how much were these
employees making and it turns out that
there was actually somebody who was the
money behind it that didn't want their
name associated with it and it was this
guy I don't even know how you say his
name it's like the word Bernard but it's
missing some letters it's just burned
bergam and he's an Austrian businessman
which is just already sounds [__]
like sick and he's uh so now he he owns
the majority of this he owns the
majority of this he worked in kind of
like Finance for a long time Goldman
Sachs he worked at Hong Kong and London
and blah blah blah he bought red tube in
2013 he sold it to mindgeek originally
and then now he bought the whole company
back and so he is the principal owner of
this thing and nobody saw it and most
people kind of thought it's a kind of a
dead asset because when you look at the
reported financials pornham makes almost
no profit and they're like geez how are
these guys making hundreds of millions
of dollars in Revenue but no profit one
of the reasons why is this guy basically
lends money to the company and takes out
two million a month in just debt
payments himself plus they shift Revenue
around all these subsidiaries so there's
all these shell companies so you don't
actually they've completely officiated
how much money this this entity makes
and so that's who currently owns it but
even he's going down now he's getting a
divorce his wife has came out and is
like she wants him to cut ties with the
company blah blah blah and I think it's
about to exchange hands again because
now a private Equity Group bought it and
do you want to know the name of the
private Equity Group that bought PornHub
yes I do ethical Capital
Partners you want to know how many
companies they own one this is the they
formed just to buy this they named it
like ethical Capital Partners is I mean
that's the uh the Subway eat fresh of uh
of private equity and so these guys are
uh now the owners of this thing and who
knows where it'll go next first of
all great story that was a great story I
was in thrall the whole time second look
up this guy Bernard it's he has a really
weird spelling there is only one photo
of him that I could find and he's
smoking a Sig bad
yeah he just smoking a sick he looks
like like if you told me that he was
part of the mob I'd believe it he looks
like either a mob guy or like a soccer
like you know the Manchester United
coach after a loss it's like one of the
two uh yeah he just he's just just
ripping a Sig uh in this in this photo
and he uh worked at Goldman so he's also
a an Acquisitions guy like he's a
dealmaker that's what he does this is
insane first of all I I would never
trade places with any of these people
maybe the original owners that is kind
of cool but the last two and the new
owner I would not trade places with any
of them for any amount of money I would
not want to go through this if you
Google this guy's name it's pictures of
his wife and them fighting over this
stuff this sounds miserable can you
imagine being married to someone who
runs this company what I want to know is
what is it like to work there how do you
stay professional like and be try to be
objective about certain stuff like you
know when you're talking about um uh at
uh Shephard or one of your companies and
you're like hey this skew is doing a
little bit better maybe we should try it
in red and blue you know we have black
let's just do it in red and blue as well
what are the conversations like at at
PornHub or or mindgeek when they're like
talking about like oh this category is
doing well let's explore that one a
little bit further you know what I mean
you know what they do right it's uh it's
the Chuck-E-Cheese tokens thing so like
if you ever just had to take cash out of
your wallet and keep putting it into
chuckecheese machines you'd be like what
am I doing this is terrible but what
they do is when you walk it and they
exchange money for these fake tokens and
then they rename everything and it feels
like it's all like you know fake you
know it's just it's like abstracted away
that's what happens because I felt this
even when we were at twitch and twitch
is a lot more reputable than this
obviously but at the end of the day we
were in these meetings that felt like
life or death high stakes everything is
on the line like the world is going to
end and I'm like this is like 21 year
olds playing video games in their
bedroom like who cares like none of this
matters and like we would hire people
from Harvard and MIT like the brightest
of the bright and they're optimizing
like you know the the mid roll ad popup
of you know some stupid energy drink in
the middle of this stupid video game
stream but none of it feels stupid once
you're in there because it becomes
abstracted away and you're playing with
the data the numbers and the revenue and
and and you come up with all these terms
for community and content and whatever
and nobody uh I feel like nobody looks
at the fact that we're all just making
hot dogs anymore you lose sense of it I
my wife worked at Facebook out of
college so she went to this Ivy GLE
School a smart woman she had all these
make job job offers whatever and she
starts working at Facebook and I'm like
oh Sarah what are you working on and she
started explaining to me in a really
complex way I'm like oh you're just
trying to come up you're just you guys
just created like a little sticker emoji
that you could put on photos so more
people share photos and it was like it
was like looking down it was like yeah
yeah that's it you know what I mean like
you you go to that moment where you
think of like Facebook is this amazing
thing of which it is but then you like
start talking to individual people was
like oh you create a thing that when I
stick my tongue out like the cartoon's
tongue goes out that's cool uh in
reality you're doing it just to get
people addicted more to posting and
sharing stuff yeah you know that's all
right it happens when we were at Camp
MFM and we're talking to Mr Beast team
and he's given us a tour of the
facilities and our group is like
billionaires and philanthropists and and
we're walking through and we're like wow
this is this is incredible these people
are geniuses tell me how do you get
people to click the thumbnail and
they're like you know we increased
brightness and saturation by 14% and
look at how many thumbnail tests we did
and we're like ah incredible work and
we're so wrapped up in it and it all
feels so real and then you come home and
you click on his video and it'll be like
train versus pit and it's like this
train is going to drive into this hole
or is it g to jump over we don't know
it's like oh wait dude I had a friend
named Ty who used to do this [__] in his
backyard that's Ty like oh you're
locking yourself in a room for seven
days like I actually know an idiot named
Jake who did that without YouTube like
he just did that and we were like
[__] Jake still in his room he's like
yeah that's what he's doing but like
when you're in it you can get in this
reality Distortion field where you feel
like you're doing God's work out there
and that's what happens in all these
companies dude it is still cool like
like I remember El mus Elon Musk gave
this talk and he's like you know you're
doing someone was like you're doing all
these amazing things uh you're sending
people to Mars you're building cars
saving the planet whatever and he's like
yeah but it's also cool just to make a
game that like entertains people like
that's cool too so I don't want to dis
discount this stuff but it is fun to put
perspective on this and be like I think
you just can't take yourself too
seriously right it's cool to do do do
your best it's cool to try to win a game
how many people are going to watch the
Super bowl next Sunday and it's you know
a bunch of guys chasing around a ball
and an arbitrary set of rules right like
if you if you look like it's cool to be
into it it's cool to be great at it but
let's also not take ourselves too
seriously let's remember like you know
what this what this is it's a game or
it's something fun or it's something
lighthearted I've met three guys who run
porn s sits some are popular some aren't
popular one of them is very popular dude
imagine running not popular porn
site all of the downside with none of
the upside you love that joke that you
just made whoever is your friend who's
running the unpopular for imagine how
bad you have to be an
execution if you can't sell boobies you
can't sell anything
dude dud like this guy launched one and
it like within three or four days it was
doing like 80 or 100,000 views a day but
he was like yeah we don't make any money
because the ads are horrible like there
there's no way to make money on this
[__] and so they had like so they had
traffic and all three of those guys I
knew who did it they're all borderline
autistic probably on the more autistic
part of that line and they were like I
remember like thinking and talking to
them I'm like yeah but doesn't this make
you feel weird this this and this and
they're like yeah but the spreadsheet
said this number and tomorrow it's going
to say this bigger number and so all I'm
just trying to I'm just looking at that
spreadsheet I that just and try to make
that number bigger and it just so
happens that it's on this website they
are all pretty black and white about
that you know what I mean yeah yeah
exactly yeah once you get in you start
operating and by the way I remember
reading once uh so max Levin who is one
of the most you know brilliant people in
Silicon Valley this guy you know one of
the co-founders of PayPal and without
Max you know there is no PayPal which
you could probably say for a couple
people but specifically uh anybody at
PayPal will tell you that Max's
technical Brilliance in fighting the uh
frauders fraud yeah kept PayPal alive
when any other money transmitting
service just died because the frauders
just had too much to gain and they were
too sophisticated and as a young company
it's really hard to defend against it
and Max like went to war with them and
actually like fended them off enough
where they succeeded it's a brilliant
programmer right chess whatever Master
brilliant programmer blah blah blah
creates PayPal this like Monumental
thing his next ACT was a company called
slide and slide basically made like
virtual pets for Myspace it was like
what it's like yeah you know like on
your Myspace profile your Facebook
profile we're going to make little apps
like so you can you know engage with
your friends and interact it's like
interact how it's like well we just
invented this app called [__] slap
where you could [__] slap any one
person a day on your on Facebook it's
like what yeah but only one and so they
then it got even Lamer didn't it it like
became an adtech company well how do you
monetize right like with all these
things how do you monetize his ads and
so they were creating slideshows and
music videos tools but anyways it was
stuff to go on your Myspace at Facebook
profiles and they go you know Max you
built slide it got really popular then
the platforms kind of shut it shut down
some of the capabilities and I think
they ended up selling to Google for some
small amount and they were like Max
what'd you learn from slide small for
him it was still a multi hundred million
dollar exit but I think they had raised
a lot of money so I don't think anybody
really made too much so I I'll never
forget this I read this quote and I
realized oh [__] this describes my life
and so I've read this like 15 years ago
still never forgot it they go what did
you learn from slide and he said what I
he goes I realize you got to be really
careful what you what projects you pick
because anything can be in optimized to
infinity and he it's like what do you
mean he goes you know we picked that we
were going to do these like widgets on
top of profiles and guess what like the
smartest people in the world can spend
every moment of every day optimizing
that to make that more engaging more
viral more addictive higher monetization
and that's what we did we spent years of
Our Lives doing that and I think that
was like his big takeaway was like he
didn't say but like the implied thing is
like kind of like what a waste like be
careful because everything can every
knob can get optimized to Infinity he he
became like the best pogo stick player
in the world yeah like and I've felt
this many times in my life and I I don't
really even know how to deal with it to
be honest because when you have the
realization you're like [__] should I
just stop or I don't know I don't want
to stop this is like my job this
successful business should I like with
my e-com store I feel this like you know
you change the color of this and then
you run this AB test you do it's like
dude what are we doing like is this like
is this what we should be doing with our
time and our life and our Creative
Energy and I do have that like kind of
existential crisis you know every few
years just think about this quote let me
be your therapist for a minute as well
as anyone else who in this situation
which is your product doesn't have to
change the world your product actually
as a CEO or owner could be I create jobs
for wonderful people and I give them a
great place to work and like most people
just want to 9 to5 and they want to play
softball on the weekends and they want
to make sure they've got good health
insurance they want to see their kids
raised and be
healthy you don't need a life-changing
thing all the time to have a badass
thing and I don't think that it's fair
to compare all these products to the
Teslas or whatever are like these
existential crisis things because like
just having a piece of clothing item or
an item of clothing that you can give to
someone or that uh makes you feel good
about yourself or a game just to play
time I mean we just have a podcast that
like you could say oh we inspire people
uh sometimes we we just jerk around and
it's just funny like that is also
awesome it's not the right thing to say
this compared to this other thing is so
stupid when it's like no you could have
all of those things and like I get
inspired listening to music and then
there's a lot of music that's just silly
dumb stuff and there's some music that
actually changes me there's some movies
that changed me and then there's Stupid
Vine skits like it's all in the same
category and that's okay we can have all
of that and my product could be creating
a workplace that people love coming and
I Inspire them or it could be uh I just
have created a future for my daughter
you know what I mean like so I don't
think that you're product necessarily
has to be the thing you're selling but
the thing you're building I mean okay I
feel better thank you that was good uh I
feel better now I'm cating jobs out here
dude no that is the truth or like you
know what I mean or you're providing for
your family for office with the number
of jobs I've created this is great yeah
yeah we have created literally half a
dozen jobs this last quarter I might
have to become the governor of the
Philippines because I've Creed all my
jobs in in the Philippines but that's
all right um can I can I just show you
one thing off this list though cuz I had
this list pulled up of the internet
sites dude look at this list just tell
me the first thing that stands out to
you and I bet you it's the same thing
that stands out to me I'm looking at the
list of the 20 most popular most visited
most used websites in the United States
well the first thing but this is not
what you're referring to duck duck goo
is number seven that's what I'm
referring to dude that's is that what
you're referring to what is it's more
popular than Yahoo and Wikipedia and
Twitter so here's the background on Duck
Dogo so duck Dogo was started probably
20 years ago I think I mean or maybe
maybe more but like it's not new started
by this guy named Gabe I think Gabe was
a mildly successful entrepreneur
Successful by any means but like amongst
Silicon Valley it was like a base hit I
think he wrote this book called traction
with Justin Mayers our friend and then
he had this whole premise of privacy
search where he said privacy is going to
be important to people we brought this
up on the pod in the very first 50
episodes we like this is so cool because
what they used to do is duckduckgo.com
likee stats you could see all their web
traffic and it was small at first it's
basically Google but you but for some
it's it's Google but somehow they don't
show you targeted ads so I don't
actually know how they make money or
what the promise is entirely you know
it's it's just ads that are targeted I
think it's ads that are either not
targeted or it's ads that are targeted
only on what you search like the term
you just search for but nothing to do
with you as a person so they're not
cooking and collecting info on you and
Hyper personalizing it to you it's just
here's an ad because you're searching or
here's an ad about you you're searching
for a car here's a car ad but we it
doesn't have to be Sam you know that
that we're tracking Ino on and we talked
about these guys a while ago because
it's kind of weird which is like this is
a significantly less good Google or at
least that's like what it appeared to be
and but we're like their traffic's
growing like crazy what the hell is
going on and now apparently they're huge
I didn't realize they were this big I
knew the trajectory was really really
good I had no idea that they' be the
fifth so it was sted 2008 by the way I
am blown away by this I I might have to
go read that damn book then which book
traction this is real traction okay I'm
in I'm in I believe you uh this is crazy
yeah it is pretty wild and I've been
I've been interested in Duck Duck Go but
I never fully got behind it because I
was like this is just an inferior uh
Google but this is amazing so they say
Duck Duck Go is an independent privacy
company for anyone who's tired of being
tracked online and wants an easy
solution and actually recently they
raised $100 million in funding or maybe
200 million but it was over 100 million
and I heard that none of the money
actually went to the company it was
simply early employees selling some of
their stake meaning the company does not
need cash they're very profitable which
makes sense because Google is like if
you know I don't know how many employees
Google has 100,000 they but like if you
fired everyone but 50 or 100 or 200
people it probably could work pretty
great I mean their main thing is like
the most efficient best business model
of all time so it makes sense why Duck
Duck Go is so uh such a good business
but this is amazing that they're what is
it number seven number seven most
popular website 10 years they went from
0.001% market share to
now 63 they're still insane they're
still tiny according to their own you
know uh measurement of of marketer um
which I don't know exactly how they
measure that because if you look at the
the uh you know Alexa rankings or the
sem rankings they're getting 10 times
less traffic than Google or a little bit
less than 10 uh um but they're saying
they're only 0 6% of search so I don't
know they had a 100 billion searches in
Q3 of
2022 I'm gonna go on the street and I'm
gonna ask a hundred people do you use
duck. go I need to know what's going on
here this is crazy I think we should I'm
not gonna go through my other topics I
think that this this you did a wonderful
job you had me in thall the whole time
What's the title of this one going to be
like uh Sean talks for 94 minutes
straight because that's what it felt
like that's every episode this one's
gonna be uh this one's gonna be uh the
story behind the fifth most popular
website in the
world um all right that's the
[Music]
pod